Gold we all know the shiny precious
metal but how precious is it how do we
put a price on it for almost a century
the benchmark price has been set twice a
day every business day by a panel of
banks in London the bank's de Waal price
they're prepared to buy and sell at
until there's a consensus the process is
called the goldfish sound a bit familiar
it should the libel benchmark interest
rate was set in a very simple way unlike
libel is concerned that the price can be
manipulated Barclays has already been
fined for letting one of its traders
manipulate the price and now fewer and
fewer banks want to be part of the
process just for banks now decide to
benchmark price for gold it was a unique
problem Silver's historic benchmark is
due to bite the dust in August only two
banks now set that Christ after Deutsche
Bank pulled out so what now for gold the
industry's been discussing changes to
how the price is set the new process
will probably be based on data from
electronic trading and with the market
work 18 trillion dollars every year
there's a lot riding on this fixed to a
fix